already
and uh i'll do some introductions later
but sam's got something to say
all right the governor of california
gavin newsom he comes up to you and says
boys
i'll give you one drone strike ooh
anywhere you want any time where are you
gonna lay down this bad boy
okay topic of the day that we're
starting with and you have that's a hot
topic you have to drone strike
something you he all he wants is a
coordinate
all right okay some thing and our slash
someone
yeah each he just wants a coordinate he
said he says
he says give me the numbers what's the
blast radius first of all i
i hope that gavin newsom doesn't have
access to guided missile strikes
i mean what but radius 40 50 meters
50 meters okay it's got a guided drone
strike precise
you can drop it or anything okay that's
100 meters diameter that's pretty uh
it's not like like there's a hunky one
you don't you don't even have to
you don't even have to hold the xbox
controller yeah yeah yeah wow
it's not like a trump trump bomb though
the old like trump bombs
no those extra xxl bombs
he's no he says you can even choose the
size of your missile oh good okay if
your answer is donald trump
you should cons you should seriously
consider leaving the united states
i don't mean that to be like oh donald
trump i just mean that like
if you're seriously considering dropping
this bomb on the president
yeah for whatever purpose you should
probably consider leaving the country
but if it wasn't him
if it doesn't matter who is president i
didn't say it has to be a person
it could you could just freaking like
mount rushmore or whatever right
wouldn't do a person i wouldn't do mount
rushmore
some people would some people would i
actually found speaking of trump and
mount rushmore
someone photoshopped trump's head as an
addition to mount rushmore
it is the funniest thing though is he
does he have the hair and everything
yeah oh yeah okay yeah yeah i i wonder
if i can just real quick show the god
cameras this is it so did they did they
put the facade like the rock facade over
it the texture and everything
oh my god that's actually pretty good so
like
oh the camera just show the camera it's
so cringy
like right next to all of those iconic
presidents yeah
and then there's here's our man he's
just the ultimate troll anyways
you know each time we hop on these
things i'm like let's not talk about
politics listen this doesn't have to
this doesn't have anything to do with
politics this is the rift cast
this is the first we're going to take
we're going to take
everything right now we're just going to
kick it in the junk that's right
um we have zero plans we don't know
where we're going we so listen
for the ride and things are going to get
weird and
you know forgive us for we know not what
we do but we're just planning to have
some fun and maybe come up with some
comedic beats here
our opinions are probably wrong some
comedic beats so anyways back to the
drone strikes okay
i need real answers all right sam
says your topic you might talk first
i'll kick it off all right
uh i'm in okay i got my map loaded up in
my mind i'm honing in
on a target uh area 51
i'm gonna shoot a missile directly into
area 51 why
because honestly there are not any alien
ufos in area 51
and if but if we blew it up people would
stop asking questions because it was
just like what it's all destroyed
do you think it would even make it or do
you think it would be intercepted by
something
look i mean you know these are
crazy questions that i didn't think
about the governor of california gavin
newsom
drone striking rick slick
[Laughter]
no no more even if there were a ufos
boom they're gone they're toast
mount rushmore the ufos guys problem
solved
not only do we have answers today we
have solutions
uh so many solutions and before we talk
about more solutions i just want you to
know this episode is brought to you by
storyblocks more on them later they have
tons of asset solutions but matt
oh wait we can use that sponsorship
perfectly for this segment where we show
some b-roll of
things exploding drone strikes and the
also uh the location right before it
says okay guys hold for b-roll in five
four no it already happened two one
before we go any further let me take a
moment and tell you about today's
sponsor
story storyblocks now we've talked about
them in the past on this channel and
that's because
they're so great to what we do over here
at corridor digital and let me tell you
why
if you're a up-and-coming creator or
you're already a professional creator
and you're just looking to expand your
arsenal of tools for all the things that
you make consider storyblocks because
they have a complete and virtually
unlimited library they're the one-stop
shop for all of your stock asset needs
they have after effects templates they
have graphics they obviously have
tons of b-roll and they have sound
effects whenever we're working on a
project
and we go into it and there's a moment
where we need something to help
fill out a scene or complete the picture
on something we go over to story blocks
and through their unlimited all-access
plan
we're able to go on pick the things that
we need for the project
download them and use them the best part
about it is when it comes to royalties
you're completely 100
in the clear there's no specialized use
you can use
everything you download from storyblocks
on things like commercials
on things like videos that you want to
post on the internet and monetize and
that's the best thing about it is it's
it's no hassle
it's really easy to use they are
constantly updating the site and adding
new stock assets all the time so that's
why we use them over here
consider using storyblocks there's a
link in the description below
or you can head on over to
storyblocks.com
corridorcast because that's a much
better way to tell them that
we sent you now back to the podcast so
yeah so anyway so it wasn't meant to be
a a branded segment and
they probably aren't gonna be too happy
with this probably but it's okay because
it's all in good faith and honestly you
know their story blocks
is uh they're great well i already did
that bit yeah
that's going to come later matt let's
hear a boy let's hear where you're going
to drop the ball
oh boy where am i going to drop the bomb
well i'm going to drop it right on those
drone strikers themselves
oh on the canoe because i don't believe
in them
oh that's an opinion that i have strikes
strikes are fake and i'm going to prove
it right here right now
by dropping the problems on the drone
strikers
because they don't exist you didn't mean
it like that did you yeah
now i do the drone strikers you're
strong striking the drone strikes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
gavin newsom but mr newsome isn't this
where we are currently working
he's like
[Laughter]
man you know i might have to like go for
something obscure then here because you
guys pick very like
very particular topics that
that apply so specifically to the to the
object
of drone striking that i feel like i
just need to go after like the entire
cast of the simpsons
sorry eric i know you can't i know you
came on animators react
but like of the simpsons like the
cartoon characters like the card
so bomb flies the card screen and then
gets animated
into the simpsons universe animated in
the canon of the simpsons universe they
all are taken out by a drone striker yes
nice that's what i would do with the
defense is it just is it the whole the
whole town
or is it the main characters uh i don't
know i don't know
his household proceeded for all of
springfield oh wow
yeah yeah you're well because think
about it it's animated it goes deep
right so it's small
you're talking about 100 yard radius
yeah you could probably fit it at all
yeah yeah within a hundred yard radius
if you guys all drawn springfield's
probably not very big in reality
if it's especially if the entire show is
on like a thumb drive sure
big bomb that's true you could drone
strike the show
all of the data man drone striking that
would be
just like can we just take a pause and
think about that for a second like is
that too much power
to ha for a person no see i don't know i
don't i don't know if we can answer that
but the question i was gonna ask is try
to imagine yourself having to make that
decision
and what information is it based off of
you're holding that drone strike
controller
the xbox controller that they control
them yeah editor drones with
and they're like press a and you're like
bro
yeah i should be pressing b right now on
this xbox controller see but
maybe not what if it's somebody that
like gasses their own citizens or like
you know
commits genocide against their own
people jake we know how deep of a
question this really is but like
like light in the mood okay sorry yeah
come on we can we can make drone strikes
fun
okay all right next topic politics
excellent listen listen cops are bad
cops are kicking back for a cab hey give
gave me a ticket all cops are bad
yeah all right anyways uh next
topic that's what acab stands for cops
are made
yeah that's yeah all cops are bad
listen okay i've got another one i've
got another doozy
oh hit us with it okay strike us with it
think about this here comes this drone
strike of an idea
we take everyone from the core crew
and we send them on we send them to
survival island
where is that well okay it's a we find
an island somewhere
in the pacific you know somewhere where
you don't have to wear a shirt
okay it's nice and warm is what i mean
there's like one or two of those yeah
yeah
and uh and and everyone has to survive
on that island for a week no food no
water
okay okay is this more like a survivor
theory or like a naked
and afraid no this isn't like reality
show
reality we should film everything so
it's a reality show jacob
i was like this is a really bad idea i
was
originally going to say that but i
realized it's the rift cast so i'm going
to
run with this yeah no food no water
yeah uh do we get like some matches or a
pocket knife
yeah here let's talk about some
essential tools yeah yeah
let's see what's the framework so you
get one what are the essentials
you get one functional water filter okay
it doesn't have you don't get water
you're on a pacific island there may be
water well you use a water filter for
to filter the water that's made from
water filters are made from fresh water
you have to you have to boil salt water
to filter that well maybe you're not
getting your water from salt water well
there's
yeah there's also like island streams if
there's like an island stream slash
waterfall scenario
it's a fertile it's a i'll just say it
this way it's a fertile tropical island
like a tropical jungle paradise giving
life to all that inhabit
right now it was like that you get that
fruit growing on every tree you get one
garden to eat in the situation you get
one k-bar knife
okay like the standard marine issue
k-bar knife
and you get uh one flint strike one
piece of flint
to make a single one flynn strike and
then they take it away
you get it you get a piece of flint like
that's like a flint that's like a rod of
flint yeah that's pretty good i mean
honestly
just being able to create fire solves
most of your problems yeah okay
so who first let's just get it kick it
off right who dies
who dies first yeah who dies first
[Music]
this is the rift cast remember anything
we say
doesn't actually make sense or mean
anything so i'm just gonna throw
something out there
daniel is very new
but he has a very sharp mind
and i think he does he doesn't despite
his
uh her persona i think he
would probably surprise all of us so i'm
not going to say it's him i think i kind
of have to do this backwards
okay i have to like success let's
figure out the people who's definitely
survived okay
we kind of figured that out
i have a feeling it's going to be me
uh okay well um i've spent some time in
the woods
i feel like i would do okay i mean i'm
not gonna say i'm not gonna guarantee
that i'd survive i might fall off of
something and die i have a tendency to
try to do that to myself but
uh so you know spend some time in the
woods
uh nick so you're just making a case for
yourself no no no no no i'm sure i
definitely want i'm just
i'm just i'm just starting with you know
what my experience has been in the woods
yeah
nick is an eagle scout yeah he would
survive
yeah he would be the the jesus natalie's
an eagle scout
yeah okay so you got two eagle scouts in
the group uh
let's see who else we got uh i'm a great
listener so
he's a great listener i'm just you
telling me to do something that'll be
there for therapeutic purpose yeah yeah
yeah yeah i go to heaven
about your problems look i've been
really feeling like
you'll be like man the days are gonna
get smaller just tell us
[Laughter]
just give us a poem that we can remember
you by can you give us something why
didn't you just
feed me though i just needed a little
food
food everyone like that's the whole
point of a civilization everyone does
different things very well yeah matt
does the poems jake starts the fire
i'm the poem guy obviously actually
everyone does the work
matt and they feed matt and in return
can you give us a poem right now can i
do that yeah like see let's see if you
might
my brain i don't think functions with
rhymes
i don't i can't doesn't have to rhyme
well that i heard you have uh
i don't want expertise in stagecraft
do you have an ex spent years backstage
hearing actors just yeah yeah blast out
cool rhymes and poems and cool quotes
from
literary history and you can't exactly
can't even conjure one up for a while
people that's why i'm behind in the back
of the stage making it
and i said you're a good listener i left
this yeah exactly
so i can listen to other people and make
poems i'll try one
i'll try you can't remember oh pacific
sun
how you are so hot during the day and
yet you go at night leaving us cold
and wanting of you but when you come
back around
you're so hot again we want you to go
away
pacific sun why don't you do something
useful for us
and kill us a large animal that we may
eat
well that's like a pre-hunt prayer
that's a great poem that's cool that i
listened to
i listened to that poem yeah i could do
it too but i don't want to bore you
i don't want to i know you won't even
listen anymore
okay so uh uh so that's the uh desert
island bit wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait we're
going
[Laughter]
are we really done with the desert
island bit i don't know it's interesting
so what else
matt you're probably not gonna die
because
anyone would let that happen to you
right i'm great at stepping on other
people too that are lower than me just
going to tell you it's probably
it's not going to be nico because nico's
literally in an area with no cell phone
reception and no electricity
and he's carried a boat for miles right
now to get to his campsite
so yeah he's probably going to handle
that tropical scenario he has
current he's training right now he's the
doctor oh
oh oh [ __ ] who's the doctor of the
island
oh
i was about to say ren because because
of his lovely wife who
is also announced yeah she may have
imbued yeah yeah
he's absorbed the information over years
some medical information yeah that we
could find useful
i like that idea okay so ren is the
doctor
is the doctor somehow when that happens
friend's the doctor yeah uh who who's
like the
uh the bank you know like who do you go
to like broker deals with other members
of the tribe
um you know i'm just i'll just i'll
volunteer
okay the volunteer is the bank guy
because yeah i think i'm pretty good at
mediating
yeah maybe like i feel like if i was in
the more high pressure situation like
this i would
mediate better yeah what's our currency
on this island
uh probably gonna use coconut chips yeah
chips coconut yeah sand
sticks that wouldn't be bad at all yeah
sticks
or rare gems well sticks have a value on
it
sticks have value on an island because
you can use them for fire that's true
that's true bow and arrows large palm
ones what i'd be concerned about
is like the water you know because the
first thing you want to do is
bear grylls yeah bear grylls taught me
anything it's
the first thing you want to do is drink
your piss
[Laughter]
first first you got to conserve energy
you got to slow down
you got to figure out your surroundings
a little bit and the next thing you got
to do
is get yourself some shelter okay and
then after you got yourself some shelter
then you got to get yourself some water
yup okay and then after that food
sure now i'd be concerned about all of
us doing that in just that order
to begin with i think our chances on the
island are probably 40 60 in favor of
of death um but what if we work together
as like a swiss family
family robinson kind of team
you know yeah ren fashions like a stick
drone
i mean i think realistically we would do
that we have this crazy
technology i'd probably just try to
partner up with nick and then broker
deals from there yeah that'd be my plan
that's cool
i'd build like a primitive technology
like shrimp catching basket
that would be like my first thing that i
would do where i basically
take jungle leaves i don't even know if
there's shrimp around and then
well like i'm just saying like i feel
like it's it's you could bet on it
i'm taking a gamble it could be for
crabbing too it's for crabbing it could
be for basically using yeah some like
uh wicker situation kind of thing make a
cool basket that i can catch some
shrimp and stream with sam's crab [ __ ]
crawfish sam's crab shack she'd be the
hottest
person sam's got crabs
sam's crabs and so yeah
basically i'd put that over like a
little like a little
kettle situation like make a little clay
yeah yeah clay burner kind of thing
you know yeah where did you get the clay
dug it up
i went to the nearest water source and i
uh
you know took a look around there's clay
in those parts so yeah
finally you know it's not that hard a
little mug a little clay make it make an
oven mud oven
yeah yeah okay now to trade shrimp or uh
for favors
for extracurricular favorites but like
no no no not like sexual favors
okay like gotcha good to know
like hey can you can you uh grab me my
my water jug
or hey can you uh you hold up a shrimp
yeah hey can you uh
yeah shrimp can you get a water jug can
you collect me some more coconut chips
servant favors
he'd have the hottest spot on the island
yeah
shrimp shack the shrimp shack that's
pretty dope that is
i would probably use my love of
stagecraft to make
a nice little platform where we can for
entertainment purposes
can we actually can we dive into that
for a second make our own movies well
you have a history in stagecraft
yeah i mean it's like i went to college
and it was like a requirement to get
into my film program
was that i had to take a couple of years
of stage craft
couple years yeah two years wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait so stagecraft
i have an idea of what it is but you can
tell me what it is much better than how
does this start yeah i would love to i
would love to get
your idea of what stagecraft is so i
imagine a play and i imagine there's
like those like walls that you build
with some like two by fours
and they just get propped up and you
take a bucket of paint you
paint a hill or you paint a hellish
landscape
or whatever you know whatever's required
it was very psyched it got satanic and
there's someone on the pulleys to move
the clouds or the water
you're you're there
a fourth grade stage play in a cartoon
i mean boats i'm i'm i i'm laughing but
i'm
kind of being a hundred percent i never
know you are i know you are
that's what i imagine spacecraft you're
not completely wrong i mean it's just
it's a lot of like
you know you build facades and like you
know
what's the first thing they teach you um
actually so i learned
lighting first like stage lighting
really yeah it's kind of cool
yeah yeah which is cool it doesn't help
much for film i mean it's they're two
completely different kinds of lighting
yeah yeah um
it's a lot more rigging uh based but i
mean
it's still like it's an interesting
thing to learn
the technical aspects of light there's
some carpentry and then carpentry
eventually
yeah then you go into building wood
chopping wood
putting that into slapping it together
building that into sets big old sets
right tell me about a set you built yeah
okay let's let's talk about sets that i
built
like uh a um into the woods
was a was one of the i imagine vanishing
point
yeah i built a lot of trees really a lot
of angry looking trees
there was one uh that was super angry
that i painted myself what
what let's let's just boil it super
angry trees
here what is the thing that people
expect about stagecraft that is
absolutely not true or what's the one
thing that people wouldn't expect
at all about stagecraft um
well what what wouldn't they expect
what's the secret i mean it's very
hands-on
like that's that's certainly it but is
there a secret i don't know you kind of
just like do what you're told
in a lot of ways so it's like an army
it's like an army it is
a lot more like an army than you might
think yeah yeah it is
it is because because there's there's
you know your teachers are really doing
the bulk of the
well it's funny how stage direction it's
funny how stagecraft
turned into motion picture yeah over
time yeah because especially like you
know you watch like uh
like white christmas or whatever like
some of these older
like very sure yeah very theatrical
stage type movies i mean hell even that
german stuff in the 30s and stuff you
know
it's basically theater that's just being
filmed
yeah and actually you know there is one
interesting thing about it like
coming from that kind of background and
then into film it's like you can see how
a lot of the
that is implemented a lot of the the
stage uh
design and construction is implemented
into sets
yeah it's very similar it's almost the
same essentially the same kind of
workflow
yeah um so that's kind of cool that's
that's very cool uh and i think that's
kind of why
in the back of these uh uh these these
film
teachers minds uh they wanted us to do
that first is just kind of have that
that sort of background for it
so if you're trapped on stage in one of
these sets
like an island just like an island which
said and you only have traffic
nails and a hammer and baby nails and a
hammer and a few
a few bucks you have to drink paint you
have to drink paint no no no this is
real easy
this is a simple you hammer the nails
into this
into the stage board and you climb you
build yourself a little ladder and you
climb your way out
that's true you just construct you
construct your way out
but it is interesting if you go back and
you watch minecraft
movies from the 30s 40s 50s 60s you
watch through
like the history cinema you can see how
it changes from this like
wide angle sort of like you know
focused on the movements of the
characters and on like the group
dynamics and there's a lot of
singing and dancing and like these very
very
coordinated movements between the groups
of people on the set
yeah and then they start introducing
things like moving takes
and like singles you know and then like
you look at it today
and obviously you still have like wides
and things like that but you think about
movies mostly and
it's like most of it for the at least
for the character dramatics
it's all like close-ups now okay what do
you think about musicals what's your
opinion on musicals in general
i like them like yeah on stage or what
about in film
i like them i mean i i think some of
them are bad some of them are cringy but
like the ones that are good and the ones
that are fun
there's always cringey something and in
any art form there's always a cringey
version
i mean yeah i gotta say i i went back
the other day and i watched the sound of
music
that's an incredible movie oh yeah okay
like i know people dog on it because
it's old-timey and whatever
but like if you go back and watch it not
only
it does like the singing and like the
dancing and the acting and all this
stuff
but also there's like throughout all of
it they're threading through this
plotline
you know that's very intricate and
there's all these emotions between like
you know the patron of this family and
then this like nun
that gets or this to be none that gets
hired to come into this family to like
serve the motherly role because the
mother has died and it's like
it's all very real and it's set in this
very real environment but it's
it's got this it's got all this magical
like essence to it from from like this
you know stuff that would only happen in
a movie type thing
um well it's kind of that gateway to
like what we know as modern cinema too
with this like big grandiose scale
yeah um that and like lawrence of arabia
those movies kind of set the groundwork
for what modern cinema is
yeah in terms of like how how they shot
landscapes and how
how big it could all be to to really
create like a theatrical experience that
was unique
um and something that you could you
couldn't do you know in
in a theater on stage you know yeah i
gotta go back and watch lawrence for
arabia oh man that movie is incredible
yeah
i just think it's kind of funny if you
think about like storytelling and it's
like
here i got a story and then someone
hears it they're like that's cool
but it's kind of boring and so the
person telling it goes back and they're
like oh man
like what if i just like sang it would
that make it more entertaining and then
they sing it and they're like huh
oh yeah yeah actually yeah it was much
more engaging basically just describing
your character but it's
way more fun it's way more fun if it
rhymes it rhymes a little bit there's a
tune it's
catchy are there any actors these days
that can sing dance and act
you got like jamie foxx the triple
threat you're talking about them true
the true original triple threat um i
don't know
jamie foxx jimmy is that an original i
don't know well no like he can sing
dance and act
yeah yeah yeah i mean like the whole
like ryan gosling emma stone thing in la
la land
that's like yeah they did that thing
ryan gosling's singing is a little weird
though but whatever
yeah you jacking you jackman
[ __ ] rip your head off
[Music]
what did he sing and dance in uh he's
in a couple he may rip me yeah yeah yeah
he also made a
movie called australia
and and uh great showman yeah
yeah i wonder what's gonna happen to
movies yeah
what's gonna happen to movies they'll be
back i don't know they'll be back
they'll be back eventually
eventually yeah it's okay the movies
will heal
they'll heal we'll be back um
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's just gonna because you know you see
all these like um
uh movies that are exclusive uh
pay-per-view
yeah kind of deals yeah you know and
they're working too it's a business
model that
like hollywood discovered with weirdly
enough trolls too
why i don't know just the trolls was
pay-per-view
yeah trolls world tour i don't know man
really
i don't watch those movies okay yeah
that was like one of the first
pay-per-view
um like only digital releases that they
put out
in it and it basically like made made
its money
back as much as it would if it was
released in
real life yeah where did they release it
oh it was on amazon i think
okay i think it was an amazing 30 bucks
for mulan like what
yeah well yeah
you pay 30 bucks to see like freaking
wwe or something you know that
pay-per-view cost wwe
summerslam but that's like an event it's
like an event you know it's like yo
we're gonna do this on pay-per-view
we're gonna chug a thousand
beers dude yeah you know what you don't
do that when you watch trolls
too you know just imagine i'm just
trying to imagine like
like 30 bucks all right kids get over
here we're watching this movie and
they're on their phones and they're like
[ __ ]
[ __ ] dollars 30 dollars a nice meal
yeah instead you're eating french fries
you're sitting on your phone
i cleaned the couch i get i love that
you're texting
can we can we talk about the wwe for a
minute
[Laughter]
like it's cool i just i just it's a
discussion i always can never
participate in because i never watch it
and i don't know
yeah anything but you went to that show
that we went to
in downtown l.a right didn't you come
with us yeah we went backstage at wwe no
oh you weren't with us yeah cause i was
like dude what is
i like i'll just show i'm just there for
like the instagram photo
you know it's like i'm not i can't i
don't want to do that i i did go to a
couple of likes
i have massive respect for the whole
operation and the drama and the
storytelling and the
physical like performance but you know
also i'm just like
it's such a different yeah yeah no
totally
but like when you're so are you saying
that you have been to like a live no
i've never been though okay
it's so different because i've been to a
couple of those there's some in orlando
where i used to live
uh yeah florida yo florida florida boy
um i had to get past the gators the
gator pit
pit yeah yeah uh but it's called tna i
think
uh yeah not tits and ass but the other
one yeah um
but and it's in like universal um and
it's my first time going and it's just
like when you're there
and you see those [ __ ] like
beating
the fake crap out of each other it's so
engaging because everyone around you is
like just
screaming and just having a great time
and just drinking
dumb amounts of beer so you just you you
yeah it's this like this sort of i don't
know it's it's like electrifying like it
gets
you don't understand what it is about it
it's like there's so many elements to it
and it brings so many different people
from so many walks of life like
obviously the wrestling stereotype is
like
you know the ignorant like you know like
country boy that's like
good you you neither believe in
everything that's happening right now
but that's so stupid because the same
people who do that like how many fake
things are in their lives
right you know what i mean so it's like
oh wrestling's fakes like almond milk
isn't real milk
[Laughter]
i'm just saying you know it's like they
just blend them up what you know people
have plenty of substitutes in their
lives across
many things so whatever yeah but what
i'm saying is like it it's
also it has all these other elements to
it that
like you can appreciate as somebody who
obviously sees it as a share
fantastic stunts yes
how good they are because there was one
pay-per-view that they did where
where what was it shane mcmahon jumped
off of like a 30-foot
cage like imagine being okay 30 feet
is higher than the roof of this building
imagine being on top of the roof of this
building and jumping off of it aiming
for a a a table a full a wooden
folding table that's this big obviously
you have pads on and everything but like
that's such a gnarly stunt and it's so
dangerous and you have to plan
and coordinate and just have the balls
to be like okay this is the moment i'm
gonna do this
i'm gonna go for it and you just
man like you have to respect that like
there's no
it takes so much coordination and effort
to like bring all of those elements
together and then like
distribute them live on camera to
whoever wants to watch it it's it's
pretty incredible
yeah i think it's under i think it's
underrated
we should bring alex barbatsis on and
just talk about wrestling or something
yeah the wrestling cast we got the rift
cast i do like that one song
put a little ass on it yeah put a little
ass on it
little ass on it i don't know that i
don't know that but i like it
whatever it is rafiki's uh song
okay oh the old ass song put your his
butt on you if you
if you cross him oh okay i can't
remember it's rafiki or not it's
somebody
so many gr there's like great actors
though that have come from
wrestling too yeah yeah tons i mean you
have the rock of course
of course austin yeah he hasn't been in
that many films but he's been in a few
uh-huh
um um our boy drax from
i forgot his real name but drax yeah
from uh guardians of the galaxy oh yeah
um yeah batista batista yeah
yeah yeah no so wow yeah
um oh yeah so they're like actually good
actors as well so
you have most of them are yeah i mean
and they're like
so over the top with when when they
perform wrestling
you go back and watch some of those i
was saying this the other day when we
were doing the rock
impersonation olympics if you go back
and watch some of those performances of
the rock
like where he gets on stage and he's
just yeah just going for it yeah
i aspire it is great performance yeah
it's very hilarious
to be like hey i wonder if i can do
where can i do the equivalent of that in
my own life
yeah i know and that is that so that
kind of brings us to like that
sort of in-person kind of difference
with
you know shows like this where it's like
there it is a big event
so doing this stuff from home like
seeing
i mean uh because i've heard a lot of
people watch they watched uh
uh hamilton at home and they're just
like not impressed with it
because i feel like that's that's
another one of those sort of like you
got to
see it in person i totally agree that
was like i saw a book of mormon last
year and
yeah i was about to bring that up or
maybe it was this year i don't even know
what time it is or where i am
seriously but it was so good and like
that live performance
like something special my [ __ ] mind i
was so
impressed with seeing how it comes
together
yeah in the moment and that that's
really what makes it impressive it's
like seeing these people just go like
hey
this isn't recorded i only have one one
shot at nailing this
and they do it and it's it's awesome
yeah and so
yeah i have i haven't seen hamilton
either uh
yeah but i don't know i like i like
funny haha uh
you know shows so like that that's more
my speed is that style of like comedy um
yeah i was we're so we've been doing
that you know we've been doing
some stuff with with them um some of the
people that were on things
yeah you can't talk about it but i was
talking with the producer of
book of mormon who's also the producer
of south park for
a long time and i go like how did you go
from
uh an animated tv series to like
producing
a traveling theater show
like where did you did you bring and
she's like well i just
you know we just decided that's what we
were gonna do
and we put our focus on it and we just
learned it
like we just we just started doing it
and started learning it and it's like
man that was that was a good cue to to
think about
oh hey uh you know if there's something
else we want to do
even here at corridor or whatever like
next step
just sure just just start getting your
feet wet and just jump in because that's
a perfect example of something that's
been incredibly successful for
somebody for a group of people that had
nothing to do with it prior
yeah i mean there's also there's systems
in place though it's like
the right people and all that but like
you still need to understand
how the whole show functions and works
because if you don't
uh you know you're gonna you're not
gonna understand like who you who you're
bringing on and what they're good at
yeah that's gonna get it it's gonna get
a little more riffy
i'm gonna get one of those hold on it's
gonna get a little more riffy on this
castle just cracked
crack the old pacifica oh all right
you're him
i mean going all in this is a joe rogan
cast now
so it's getting a little more real so
coronavirus real or fake
virus real or fake oh
man i have one more thing to say about
book of mormon though actually and it's
very
it's very funny because i because um
when i when i watched it i watched it in
orlando
and there's they have this whole uh uh
song
about orlando specifically and when i
watched it the first time first of all
the audience lost their damn minds
when when he started singing in orlando
it's a home team yeah it was and it's so
[ __ ] hard too it's awesome
um and uh yeah and i didn't realize that
they
they just that's just how it was written
i thought that they did that
everywhere until i talked to someone
else who like watched it here it's like
the butt end of the whole joke
yeah i know that this like closeted uh
like gay mormon guy
is just he's dreamt his whole life
of going well actually no he's not he's
just no no he no he's
he's not the gay one anyways the point
is is that yeah it's just showing how
sheltered he is living in utah yeah and
then
thinking of seeing disney world and real
life thinking that orlando is it is like
heaven yeah yeah because it was like
there's universal studios
as a child same here yeah yeah i was
like dude you're going to orlando
there's there's an inside joke i went to
orlando when i was like 13 and it was
we went to all the theme parks and it
was just like dude orlando's incredible
[ __ ]
no kills
it does kill it rocks it [ __ ] rocks
yeah okay anybody wants to visit orlando
not live there
towers in the shape of mickey mouse yeah
yeah they do
i mean yep what else mickey's world my
first time making
my first time in orlando i was like it
was amazing i was like uh
like an early teenager uh then i went
back for
a playlist live yeah and that was
murder because it was like it was like
hey you guys you always want to go to
playlist live because
you make a youtube channel and i was
like all right here we go and we go to
it and it's just like
holy [ __ ] first first off playlist live
is not vidcon
it is it is like we weren't we are not
14 year old influencers
yeah with 12 year old fans yeah yeah and
so it was we were very out of place
and then it was like well [ __ ] what else
is there to do is there any restaurant
across the street
you have to hop across the gator pit run
across an open freeway because there's
no sidewalks
they got a lot of gator pits in florida
guys you just gotta watch out for them
they're sneaky with them yeah it was
just like jesus christ
we're trapped here
there's no leaving you can't leave we
didn't know what to do we
did we did our event the thing we were
supposed to do to be there
and then we were like okay what do we do
and there like we met with some people
you know drank pina colada and then we
were like what are you gonna do
we there's a there's like a cuban or a
mexican restaurant across the street and
and we're like oh let's just go over
there oh man and we went over there and
it was like totally
different yeah where we just were and in
a good way and in a bad way
yeah we sat there and we just had pina
coladas and like
yeah chips and salsa there's so much fun
to be had even just making fun of
orlando like we actually made a sketch
that's called if orlando was a movie and
it was basically just like it we just
make the most hardcore action trailer
yeah but it's about living in orlando
like the whole premise is just like i'm
in orlando and did you grow up there
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah so like within
the city or suburbs sure yeah
there's what's called the windermere and
actually yeah like i'm sure like where
we were
it's like during in that area the disney
area it's like yeah that's
i'm sure there's like a relatively
normal part of orlando it's like in the
lion king where the the place where the
shadow is that's
i drive that area you just don't go
there you don't go there
okay um but where i lived is yeah the
shadow lands yeah
yeah um but where where i lived was
actually
it was the most it's one of the biggest
mormon temples really in the country
yeah it's huge and it's like kind of the
landmark for where i
where my neighborhood was okay so yeah
just just look at the crystal on the top
of the mormon church yep
yeah where the light is the light shines
right and there's my place
it actually shines directly onto my
house yeah
yeah that's um you know the mormons they
they're around
yeah no they are people they're just in
utah they're among us
people think they're just in utah but
it's you know
look i've i've never had an issue with a
mormon i'm not gonna lie no they're no
they're great they're so nice i actually
dated one i think that has been the
nicest people that's the thing that's
that's their is that within their i
think they actually
think because it was a weird sort of
thing where it's like we were dating but
not
because she didn't want to i don't think
she wanted to tell her to convert
yeah i think so right yeah that's kind
of a thing yeah yeah yeah
the whole reason why my family became
catholic is because my
two grandfathers on both sides uh
they really wanted to marry uh uh like
balkan women like slavic women
oh and they were obviously catholic and
uh so they had to convert
and so to slavic no to catholics
they were an attorney slavic no they
were proudest okay
yeah they was the other way around they
begrudgingly put on their track pants
for the wedding their blue contacts in
they're like oh [ __ ] you're right
white fish the red adidas track
just part of it it's part of the deal
man sorry we're not sorry
it's cool yeah there's so many funny
stereotypes about slavic people
yeah it's kind of an obscure region of
europe like it's not really well known
yeah anything in particular but they
talk funny so
they talk funny yeah yeah
um and the track and in norway too like
those
oh yeah that area oh yeah yeah yeah
sick sick sick bro so
um hey one other thing uh what's going
on with these mailboxes
they're rounding up the mailbox this is
this is by the way it was a preface
a topic we did not want to talk about
because none of us know what we're
talking about no one wants to talk about
it because
because like no one there's not even a
straight story any real
out there he likes the problem the
postal service is just like uh we're
actually replacing him with more
up-to-date mailboxes like
it's a [ __ ] steel it's like an iron
box painted blue it's like what there's
ipads in it
well it's funny it's funny what people
notice when things become
like when things raise up into the
cultural zeitgeist like
for example uh there's plenty of
mailboxes around here you go you drop
off your mail right it's standard
standard operating procedure well
usually one of the other operating
procedures that
oftentimes people don't know about is
that the mail uh the
the post office comes around at night
and they lock those boxes in certain
neighborhoods because
the people people steal from them we had
this happen to us
um and uh so they lock them and then
apparently there was somebody the other
day who was tweeting about how there was
a mailbox that was locked in burbank and
they were like
the mailboxes are locked guys the
mailboxes are locked
and it's like drumsticks
it's funny what it's funny what like
taking up boxes a totally innocent
operating procedure can like all of a
sudden just get like
clipped by like this other thing that's
happening that has nothing to do with it
yeah whatever yeah it's funny sure yeah
so yeah at the end of the day
sure those mailboxes those those
pictures that are like headline photos
of mailboxes being taken away in these
big flat bed trucks
that could be standard there's another
yeah they should be it could could be
standard there's another picture of one
a bunch of new ones just kidding right
yeah they just they photoshop that out
i mean who knows they're just sh they're
the same mailbox but they're just
shinier
i hope that everything goes well yeah me
too
because me too it'd be a shame it would
be a shame
yeah but i don't know yeah there's just
there's so much like i just feel like in
general this year there's
there's like extra layers of conspiracy
everywhere so many
likes and conspiracy that like that that
gets
the headlines and gets close to the
forum so here we go
we naturally landed on our own
they move mailboxes all the time based
on mail volume
right and basically because of all the
crazy
people like freaking out about
mailboxes they issued a statement
recently that
they basically said look you all can't
handle it when we just like are
messing with our property so we'll just
have an agreement here which is
we're not gonna [ __ ] with mailboxes
until after the election just so no one
freaks out anymore right yeah and
just like because no one could that's
probably fine it's probably not a bad
idea considering
one guy sees a lock on a mailbox and
then like thinks the world's gonna
blow up um yeah no
it's uh so here's my conspiracy go for
it when i hear it
so so it's like when was the last time
that this kind of stuff happened
civil war no 2016.
um with the with the russians the
previous elections
and it seems like you know this is this
is very like someone pulling the strings
which i
uh seems like but like there's a lot of
soros george soros is out there pulling
the strings
yanking those american citizenship
putin's taking on our mail okay
putin's got all right he's reading the
grandma's letters he's reading
every single letter
yeah no like it's just it just seems
like every year there's
a major election it's like why does this
stuff have to go on like this
can't we all just get along are we all
on the same team yeah
when we were everyone thought everyone
thought the last election was high
stakes they're like
trump is the worst candidate ever like
if he's elected
the economy is going to crash he's going
to be
arrested and he's going to jail
and then mike pence is going to have to
be president because he's so obviously
going to jail and now it's like
yo bro if trump gets elected people are
literally gonna riot now this time
because like
yeah it's like yeah it's true and i mean
even if it's 100 legit it's like i
obviously i'm not gonna vote for the guy
yeah but
like jesus christ so and but i think the
problem is like you can have
denying on either side here like
regardless of
the result it's like i mean even our
president's talking about like
well we'll see let's not talk about
let's not talk about voting because like
who you vote for for president does not
determine who you are as an individual
for sure
like look at the choices yeah no i know
i know and at the end of the day it's
like we all have different people
like there's these giant issues and it's
like there's a wash of all these
different things that are relevant to
you as an individual
and like i wish we could all just like
take a moment and step back and go like
look like there's people are making the
best decision that they can make for
themselves
and some people are doing it
pragmatically some people are doing it
on singular
issues some people are doing it because
they feel about x y and z
and there's only two people you can vote
for and so let's let's take a step back
and go
like hey maybe it doesn't mean you're a
you're a blood
thirsty baby killer if you vote for x y
or z
yeah exactly it's like saying oh yeah
these two people boil down
the like 300 400 million americans
it's like right there's only there's 200
million americans
who are like trump and there's 200
million americans that are like biden
apparently
right yeah apparently yeah evidently
evidently there's 200 trumps
200 million trumps and 200 million biden
i mean that's the other thing too
i've been looking for them i've been out
there on the streets with binoculars
you're racist goggles yeah is that
racist spotters yeah i mean look there
are other people on the ballot
just throwing it out there yeah you
might feel like you're wasting your vote
um but it's only you're only wasting
your vote if
you don't vote for someone who you
actually
want to be he would do the best job yeah
like that's all it comes down to like
who
who who practically would do the best
job right now
and that's the subjective question or
the subjectivity yeah it's like i'm like
okay we need to build we need someone
who's an expertise in stagecraft here
all right no i got you baby
and we do this office challenge
stagecraft office challenge
and here's the thing though jake's got a
ton of power tools at his disposal and
we know that he's probably gonna do it
he he'll build a stage but we know that
there's one man here
who will do the best job so it's like
who do you vote for do you
go for this guy who maybe you know he's
got some more points
or do you go with the expert and it's
like ah well sorry matt i know you would
actually build the best stage
but i feel like you're not going to win
so i'm not going to vote for you yeah
it's like and jake has better hair
yeah yeah he's going to have to consider
that cool hairdo you got to consider
that i just i don't know it just seems
that's how gavin knew someone it was all
about that
oh about the hair man good looking guy
man yeah it's easy to vote for him when
he's like hey
hey what's up yeah i cheated on my wife
but i won't cheat on you i promise i
won't cheat on americans
don't cheat on california would never do
that
i can lie to my wife but not to the
people
oh lord ah this was great we should
totally do more of these oh the rift
the rift cast i feel like is like open
forum by the way
just full disclaimer guys if you've been
offended by anything
we've said on this podcast there's two
things that you should do okay
number one comment subscribe number one
subscribe now
[Music]
it was pretty tame subscribe not like
this we talked about like black lives
matter again
yeah yeah yeah i only said [ __ ] trump a
couple of times
it's fine we're good look we've i think
we've covered actually offensive topics
drone strikes
yeah like everyone's hearing that he's
given a full disclaimer i feel like it's
the right thing to do but anyway you
know what i'm saying yeah no
jake you're 100 right though well this
was a lot of fun we should do another
one
we should okay right now let us know in
the comments
if you guys want to do us to do another
riff cast be happy to do it it was a lot
of fun riffs cast
i think we found a new format yeah
indeed we did
it's all about not taking things too
seriously and honestly
you kind of put yourself you have to put
yourself out on a limb there you know
it's like
sometimes you don't know the facts but
don't let that stop you
from throwing all kinds of opinions out
there you know i think we've got
all kinds of opinions to share that's
the best way
all right cheers guys thanks for
listening later see you later